en este vídeo quiero hablar acerca de
algo que probablemente sea uno de los
conceptos fundamentales y profundos de
la estadística y quizás de todas las
matemáticas y este es el teorema del
límite central
teorema del límite central
y lo que nos dice es que podemos empezar
con cualquier distribución que tenga una
media y varianza bien definidas digamos
si tiene una varianza
no se puede ser una distribución
continua o discreta voy a dibujar una
discreta porque es más fácil de imaginar
en al menos para los propósitos de este
vídeo entonces digamos que tengo una
función de distribución de probabilidad
discreta y quiero hacer cuidadoso de que
esto no se apareció una distribución
normal para que vean el poder del
teorema digamos que tengo una
distribución que toma valores 1 2 3 4 5
y 6
digamos de algún dado medio loco y
digamos que es muy probable que
obtengamos el 1 que vamos a obtener 1
muy probable 2 pues más 2 no perdón 3 y
4 pues más o menos y el 6 también es muy
probable de obtenerlo entonces esta es
mi función de distribución de
probabilidad digamos que si fuese a
dibujar la media
más o menos esto es simétrico entonces
la media estaría a la mitad con cierta
desviación standard no sé no sé cómo sea
pero bueno esta es mi mi función de
distribución de probabilidad discreta
ahora lo que voy a hacer es en vez de
tomar muestras de esta variable
aleatoria que está escrita por esta
función de distribución voy a tomar
muestras de ella pero voy a tomar el
promedio de esas muestras y luego voy a
mirar y ver la frecuencia de los
promedios que obtengo y cuando digo
promedio déjenme definir lo siguiente
entonces digamos que el tamaño de la
muestra
es n
es en 4 ok y lo que significa es que voy
a tomar 4 muestras de esto digamos que
la primera vez tomó 4 muestras digamos
que obtengo 1 1 luego un 3 y luego un 6
entonces esta es nuestra primera muestra
de tamaño 4 sé que la terminología puede
ser un poquito complicada pero esto nos
está diciendo que tenemos una muestra de
4 muestras es decir la muestra es una
muestra de cuatro elementos que tomamos
de nuestra distribución es decir se
refiere al conjunto de muestras de la
distribución y el tamaño nos dice
cuántas realmente tomaste de esta
distribución la terminología puede ser
confusa porque puedes fácilmente ver uno
de estos como una muestra pero estamos
tomando cuatro de ellos es decir tenemos
una muestra de cuatro y lo que voy a
hacer es tomar el promedio vamos a tomar
el promedio sale ok cuál es el promedio
de esta primera muestra
así que tengo uno más uno es 2 3 son 5 y
6 son 11 y 11 dividido entre 4 es 2.75
esta es mi primera media muestral de
tamaño 4 muy bien déjenme hacer otra
digamos que mi segunda muestra digamos
que obtuve un 3 y un 4 otro 3 tal vez y
un 1 no sea solo se me ocurrió quizás no
salió el 6 ya cuente que el 2 y el 5 no
pueden aparecer sale entonces la
probabilidad de obtener 2 y 5 o 5 más
bien es cero entonces para esta segunda
muestra de tamaño 4 nuestra media
muestral
baja la media muestral sería 3 473 son
10 1 es 11 y otra vez entre 4 nos da
2.75
déjenme hacer una más porque realmente
quiero que se vea de que estamos
hablando entonces digamos que tengo una
muestra otra vez de tamaño 4 digamos que
tengo voy a tomar
se dan cuenta esta muestra está hecha de
muestras verdad pero bueno digamos que
en esta última muestra obtuve 1 1 6 y 6
entonces mi media muestra 'la va a ser
uno más uno que es 2 más 6 son 86 son 14
y 14 entre 4 es a 33.5 verdad es 3.5 y
mientras estoy encontrando estas medias
muestrales para cada una de mis muestras
de tamaño 4 halló la media y vamos a
graficar las en una distribución de
frecuencias y esto va a sorprenderte en
algunos segundos más adelante entonces
gráfico todo esto en una distribución de
frecuencia digamos que en mi primera
muestra la la media muestral fue 2.75
entonces gráfico la frecuencia de estos
números es decir obtuve hasta ahorita
una vez
2.75
luego la siguiente vez obtuve también
2.75 ahí está así que lo obtuve dos
veces entonces obtengo ahora gráfico una
vez que obtuve 3.5 digamos que anda de
este lado baja entonces obtuve una vez
lo gráfico aquí y lo que voy a hacer es
seguir tomando todas estas muestras tal
vez 10.000 y entonces seguiré tomando
estas muestras
digamos dijimos que hasta la muestra
10.000 y vamos a ver cómo a través del
tiempo ok voy a tener que poner puntos
mejor si lo miro así digamos a lo largo
de las muestras los valores que pueden
tener los voy graficando con sus
frecuencias entonces el primer punto es
de estar aquí mismo digamos este que
había puesto en rojito y luego el
segundo punto lo colocó ahí digamos a
canda el 3.5 en fin voy a tener 10.000
veces de estos entonces si lo sigo
graficando simplemente buenas
a continuar graficando las frecuencias
una y otra vez y lo que veremos es que a
medida que tomó muchas muestras de
tamaño 4
voy a tener algo que se vaya a aproximar
a una distribución normal entonces cada
uno de estos puntos representa una
incidencia de una media muestral y a
medida que siga agregando yo en esta
columna digamos aquí obtuve varias de
2.75 y voy avanzando a lo largo de las
muestras y se aproxima una distribución
normal y este es un resultado muy buena
onda acerca del teorema del límite del
límite central entonces el teorema nos
dice que esta distribución naranja para
n igual a 4 que era el tamaño de la
muestra sí sí hago la misma cosa con un
está con una muestra digamos de tamaño
20 entonces tengo una distribución medio
loca y original inicialmente pero los
datos de mi variable aleatoria
si voy graficando la la media muestral
en una
gráfica de frecuencias que se verá a lo
mejor así no lo vamos a discutir en unos
vídeos más adelante pero resulta que si
fuera a graficar 10.000 de estas
muestras ahora voy a tener algo así que
se aproxima también a una distribución
normal vamos a ver que en vídeos más
adelante que tenemos este
tenemos la misma media vamos a tener la
misma media pero va a tener una
desviación estándar menor de hecho
debería graficar un poquito distinto
esto porque se va apilando verdad de
hasta el fondo pero entonces se va
aproximando cada vez más a una
distribuye distribución normal y la
realidad es que es un resultado genial
acerca este es el teorema del límite
central que a medida que la muestra el
tamaño de la muestra se vuelve más
grande digamos tiende a infinito y digo
realmente no no es infinito sino que se
hacen cada vez más grande de hecho no es
tan grande lo que se necesita a veces
con 10 o 20 ya es suficiente pero lo que
es muy muy increíble es que esta
distribución loca original no tiene nada
que ver con una distribución normal pero
si tenemos una muestra digamos un tamaño
mes muestra 'la de n igual a 10
tomamos 100 de estos en vez de 4 y
gráfica mos la frecuencia de las medias
muestrales y luego tomáramos otros 100
y así lo hiciéramos una una cantidad de
veces muy grande digamos que prendiera
infinito también encontraríamos una
distribución normal perfecta ese es la
parte loca del asunto y no solamente
aplica tomando la media muestral
también
si pudimos haber tomado sólo la suma
muestra y el teorema del límite central
seguiría aplicando pues esto es lo útil
de esto porque en la vida hay muchos
tipos de procesos proteínas chocando
contra otras personas haciendo cosas
locas humanos interactuando en extrañas
maneras gente abriendo facebook y no
sabes la función de distribución de
estas cosas o el teorema del límite
central nos dice que si tomamos muchas
de estas acciones y las montamos y
asumimos que todas tienen la misma
distribución entonces la frecuencia de
las medias muestrales vamos a obtener de
ahí una distribución normal y esto es lo
que hace francamente lo que hace que la
distribución normal sea tan útil en
estadística y francamente es una muy
buena aproximación de la suma de las
medias de muchos procesos
esta es una distribución normal y lo que
te voy a mostrar en los siguientes
vídeos es que mientras incremente su
tamaño de la muestra mientras tu n tomes
muchas muchas y muchas cada vez más esta
gráfica de frecuencias se parecerá cada
vez más a una distribución normal